In this lecture, we'll use a
technique called Bag of Words
to build text analytics models.
Fully understanding text is
difficult, but Bag of Words
provides a very simple approach.
It just counts the
number of times
each word appears in the
text and uses these counts
as the independent variables.
For example, in the sentence,
"This course is great.
I would recommend this
course my friends,"
the word this is seen twice,
the word course is seen twice,
the word great is
seen once, et cetera.
In Bag of Words, there's
one feature for each word.
This is a very simple approach,
but is often very effective,
too.
It's used as a baseline
in text analytics projects
and for natural
language processing.
This isn't the
whole story, though.
Preprocessing the
text can dramatically
improve the performance of
the Bag of Words method.
One part of
preprocessing the text
is to clean up irregularities.
Text data often as many
inconsistencies that will cause
algorithms trouble.
Computers are very
literal by default.
Apple with just an uppercase A,
APPLE all in uppercase letters,
or ApPLe with a mixture of
uppercase and lowercase letters
will all be counted separately.
We want to change the
text so that all three
versions of Apple here will
be counted as the same word,
by either changing all words
to uppercase or to lower case.
We'll typically change all
the letters to lowercase,
so these three versions
of Apple will all
become Apple with
lower case letters
and will be counted
as the same word.
Punctuation can
also cause problems.
The basic approach
is to deal with this
is to remove everything
that isn't a standard number
or letter.
However, sometimes
punctuation is meaningful.
In the case of Twitter, @Apple
denotes a message to Apple,
and #Apple is a
message about Apple.
For web addresses,
the punctuation
often defines the web address.
For these reasons, the
removal of punctuation
should be tailored to
the specific problem.
In our case, we will remove
all punctuation, so @Apple,
Apple with an exclamation
point, Apple with dashes
will all count as just Apple.
Another preprocessing
task we want to do
is to remove unhelpful terms.
Many words are
frequently used but are
only meaningful in a sentence.
These are called stop words.
Examples are the,
is, at, and which.
It's unlikely that
these words will improve
the machine learning
prediction quality,
so we want to remove them to
reduce the size of the data.
There are some potential
problems with this approach.
Sometimes, two stop
words taken together
have a very important meaning.
For example, "The Who"-- which
is a combination of two stop
words-- is actually the name
of the band we see on the right
here.
By removing the stop words,
we remove both of these words,
but The Who might actually
have a significant meaning
for our prediction task.
Another example is the
phrase, "Take That".
If we remove the
stop words, we'll
remove the word "that," so the
phrase would just say, "take."
It no longer has the
same meaning as before.
So while removing stop words
sometimes is not helpful,
it generally is a very
helpful preprocessing step.
Lastly, an important
preprocessing step
is called stemming.
This step is motivated
by the desire
to represent words
with different endings
as the same word.
We probably do not need to draw
a distinction between argue,
argued, argues, and arguing.
They could all be represented
by a common stem, argue.
The algorithmic process of
performing this reduction
is called stemming.
There are many ways to
approach the problem.
One approach is to
build a database
of words and their stems.
A pro is that this approach
handles exceptions very nicely,
since we have to find
all of the stems.
However, it won't
handle new words at all,
since they are not
in the database.
This is especially
bad for problems
where we're using data
from the internet,
since we have no idea
what words will be used.
A different approach is to
write a rule-based algorithm.
In this approach, if a word ends
in things like ed, ing, or ly,
we would remove the ending.
A pro of this approach is that
it handles new or unknown words
well.
However, there are
many exceptions,
and this approach would
miss all of these.
Words like child and children
would be considered different,
but it would get other
plurals, like dog and dogs.
This second approach
is widely popular
and is called the
Porter Stemmer, designed
by Martin Porter in 1980,
and it's still used today.
Stemmers like this one have
been written for many languages.
Other options for
stemming include
machine learning,
where algorithms
are trained to recognize the
roots of words and combinations
of the approaches
explained here.
As a real example
from our data set,
the phrase "by far the best
customer care service I
have ever received"
has three words
that would be stemmed--
customer, service,
and received.
The "er" would be
removed in customer,
the "e" would be
removed in service,
and the "ed" would be
removed in received.
In the next video, we'll see
how to run these preprocessing
steps in R.